leap candidates for 2021
non-quarterbacks right are we are we
we're definitely non-quarterbacks
because i prepared this as did i see
that non-qb okay i i wasn't uh i wasn't
misinformed chris i'll let you have the
first pick
okay um i'm gonna go i'm gonna go i'm
gonna take a shot in the dark with one
here i'm gonna almost take it just
because i feel like he's gotta make the
leap to a degree
i'm gonna go with nicole hardman i think
this is the year you know i mean for the
sake of this right here i mean he's the
guy that we've kind of been waiting to
come along we saw it last year some
moments where you go oh i i like it
now there's no sammy watkins there he's
gone you know they did draft him in the
second round he's got to have more of a
presence on the offensive side of the
ball so
yeah i'm gonna go with nicole hardman
that offense uh i think this is the year
he breaks out a little bit
so because he should you think he will
yeah i i mean yeah that's i'm i kind of
took some some i have some guys on my
list that are that of that i go yeah i'm
making a projection i'm like calling my
shot yeah maybe not like the most
obvious one in the world i'm just
i feel like he should i feel like he's
got the talent he's in the offense that
fits them uh it's year three it just
seems like the stars are aligned for
this is the year you do it this is the
year if you want to you know make a
career in the nfl and be a receiver for
a long time you can establish yourself
as that well it's either going to be him
or byron pringle it's going to be one of
them that's what from tyreek right right
and maybe it's going to be pringle i i
wouldn't have gone with hardman because
even though i think he should i'm not
complaining i'm sure
yeah
i gave you the first pick man it was
right on the plate i can't believe you
did it i can't believe you did it and
you could argue he's already declared
himself but the stats at the end of the
day weren't what they could have been or
what they could be this year especially
if his team establishes the run oh man
they can maybe do a little play
[Music]
how do you not take chase claypool right
out of the gates and you know they
didn't play him as much as they could
have his snaps i remember at one point i
went through
the game books and i looked at his
playing time and i'm like why is this
guy only on the field 30 of the time he
should be out there all the freaking
time i think he'll be out there more
this year i think they'll have the ball
arcing through the air to him more often
they understand what he can do i think
he makes a leap this year yeah i'm not
gonna
i'm not gonna disagree at cor you know i
don't know why i did that i just
outthink myself sometimes he's the first
name i have written down
mean it's just stupid it really is all
right you didn't have to worry about me
taking nicole hartman i know i exactly
right it was really stupid i don't even
know what i was supposed to say there
okay now the next one i'm going to go
with
i'm gonna go with one that's a little
more along those lines okay but like
breakout gear
even though you know i think he's kind
of broken out but this is a guy that i
just it seems like i have to draft him
in a draft i'm going terry mclaurin i
think this is the year he breaks out and
everybody goes holy crap this guy's a
superstar has
i didn't know he was this good yeah i
think it's the year cause they got you
know everything you need on the offense
a sp and a quarterback finally that i
think you take advantage of everything
he can offer
at that position fitzpatrick's not going
to be shy about chucking the ball down
the field and mclaren to me has some of
that tyreke hill-ish type of ability
that way there's three rockets up his
ass he gets in the open it's see you
later and he can run by you whether it's
slants and catch after the run or just
straight bombs uh that's where i'm gonna
go with terry mclaurin
yeah i it doesn't feel like a breakout
because i know you've been all over now
but the numbers maybe haven't been at
the level where they will be and then it
will reflect or should reflect the jump
and that's kind of where i am this isn't
a surprise for us because we've seen it
coming and it happened late in the year
and we've heard the praise from his head
coach and others on his team and when
you consider now the upgraded
quarterback in la cam akers
is gonna go from being
kind of like fringe guy
hey
yeah okay yeah he had a good game
thursday night against the patriots okay
fine no he's going to become the guy
that they're they're
they're ditching
the
let's emulate the 49ers with three
running backs and let's get back to
having one guy who's the guy and it's
going to be cam akers this year in l.a i
i i could see that that's a good pick by
you i didn't have that uh written down
but that's that's a solid one because i
think that could be a a big time
breakout you know year for him you're
right it seems like they want to kind of
make him the guy that offense should be
a lot more open with staffer and his
ability to chuck the ball that way so
all right i like that i like that a lot
um
man i got a lot of good ones here i'm
not sure where to go
well you've been holding them back well
i know yeah i i know what was i thinking
that was so stupid uh i'm i i i don't
know does this consider breakout i i
that's where i'm a little like i want to
say bradley chubb that's who i want to
take in denver like does that that
consider like yeah right i mean he had
set the rookie record for sax
that's where i was a little but like
he's coming off an injury right no but
he's not a household name nobody knows
that like that you just said right there
nobody knows it so that's why i'm saying
break out is that still okay for this
draft that's fine okay good i think you
made the point for me because nobody
knows that's that and you know he has
been injured von miller going to be back
all those type of things i just think
yeah he's two years removed right from
his own knee injury i think this is the
year where everybody just goes holy crap
this definitely is one of the best
passengers in football and he sets
himself up for a long-term contract with
the denver broncos or whoever else and
and there we go so i'm gonna go with
bradley chubb
12 as a rookie one in his second season
before he toured the acl seven and a
half
last year with some injury limitations
all right i i uh
i successfully held
my my trump card until the end i thought
maybe you'd take him this is something
that we danced around a week and a half
ago
when the titans added julio jones
because when you look at the titans
targets
where'd everybody go it was just aj
brown everyone else is gone john w smith
is gone hello anthony fercer because
with everyone focused on aj brown
and julio jones
fercz is going to be running around
waving his arms
saying here i am ryan i'm wide ass open
throw me the ball so put me down for
anthony fercer okay titan's tight end
yeah i i it's a good pick it really is
he's a good player he really is i mean
he can he can do it all and i mean he
he's more dangerous than in the past
game than i think people realize i mean
he could catch the ball and take off and
get yards after the catch i think that's
you know part of what they had a balance
there with paying jonu smith and
realizing what they got at the position
yeah he's not as talented but he's still
pretty damn good and you're right kind
of a forgotten man there
as far as that's concerned um
oh i uh all right
all right oh is it me am i up oh that's
it right go ahead you're up it's round
four if you want to go go ahead you said
you got a bunch of good ones i'll tear
one i'm i'm stuck with like two here
okay i might as well just talk it out a
little bit like there's two guys that i
tj hawkinson of detroit right i could
see him first off he came came on he's
really talented and the other one i
think about is isaiah simmons with with
the arizona cardinals right i think they
finally they found his position they got
it locked down he started to pop a lot
on film as the end of the year at the
end of the year went on last year there
to where i started to go where this
kid's got it i think he's getting
comfortable at middle linebacker um so
i'm just throwing those two out not that
uh you don't have to you know put them
on a graphic or whatever but hawkins so
which one so are you taking one are you
taking one are you i'm gonna go hockey
i'm gonna go hawkinson
yeah hawkinson's the one i'll go with i
just think he has got top five tight end
type talent and uh with this offense
anthony lynn everything dan campbell
being a tight end head coach this is the
year he goes off
one guy that i was tempted to take was
jamal williams the lions running back
who came from the packers yeah i'm still
not sure what the distribution is going
to be between him and deandre swift
right but i'm intrigued by what he can
do and i think from a personality
standpoint we're going to get to know
him we're going to like it but my
official fourth round pick will be
denzel mims oh good one the second under
last year who only played in nine games
last season missed seven due to injury
and uh hey
you got zach wilson he's got to throw it
to somebody exactly he's got to throw it
to somebody and all i've heard and i
know my dad even on my podcast i mean
i just hear it's a laser beam show in
new york with the jets that's all i've
heard laser beams freaking laser beams
sharks with laser beams on their head
all over the field
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports